hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about balancing selection balancing
selection is an interesting phenomenon
when natural selection maintains two or
more phenotypic forms in a population so
rather than natural selection favoring
one phenotype over another and over time
that one phenotypic form becoming far
more common or perhaps the only here to
the corner of the population instead two
or more are maintained at relatively
stable frequencies now there are two
different mechanisms that can lead to
balancing selection these are
heterozygotes advantage and frequency
dependent selection so let's talk about
what each of these are and look at an
example each heterozygote advantage is
when a heterozygote and individual
having one allele for each of those
phenotypic forms when they have a
greater fitness than either homozygote
so again the homozygotes would have two
alleles for one of the forms or two
alleles for the other form the
heterozygote has one allele for each and
because the heterozygote has a greater
fitness meaning the better ability to
survive and therefore we produce then
both of these alleles meaning both of
the forms both of the phenotypic forms
are maintained in the population now
these heterozygotes are often referred
to as carriers
this is true only when at least one of
those alleles so one of the alternative
forms of the gene encoding these two
different phenotypes when one is
considered a disease trait now we see an
example of both heterozygote advantage
and heterozygotes being carriers in the
disease sickle cell anemia
now sickle cell trait means having one
allele for sickle cell anemia and one
regular allele and of course we're
talking about alleles for a specific
polypeptide and hemoglobin and when the
different polypeptides are present if
you have the disease polypeptide present
than you have sickle cell anemia now so
people who have two alleles for sickle
cell trait meaning two alleles for that
incorrect hemoglobin polypeptide they
have sickle cell anemia so this is one
type of homozygote the other type of
homozygote is when they have two non
sickle cell trait alleles however so
they don't have sickle cell anemia but
they tend to be pretty susceptible to
malaria the heterozygote on the other
hand is a carrier for sickle cell trait
they do have one sickle cell allele but
they also have one regular O'Neill now
that regular allele is the one that when
present twice in a person leads to
success leads to susceptibility to
malaria
however these heterozygotes actually
have a really big advantage because they
are resistant to malaria as a result of
having one of the sickle cell trait
alleles but because they don't have to
they don't have sickle cell anemia so
the heterozygotes they don't have sickle
cell anemia and they're pretty resistant
to malaria which means that in regions
where malaria
a common problem and populations both of
these alleles are maintained in the
population again at relatively stable
frequencies because when they're present
in heterozygotes they are advantageous
together but again when you have a
homozygote so someone who has two of the
same regardless of which phenotypic form
it is then they have issues that reduce
their fitness relative to the
heterozygotes
so that is heterozygote advantage now
let's talk about frequency dependent
selection which is another type of
mechanism that maintains two or more
phenotypic forms in a population now the
same idea is at play and that idea is
thinness so frequency dependent
selection is when the fitness of a
specific phenotype is dependent on its
frequency in the population and
specifically its frequency relative to
other phenotypes in the population a
really cool example of this is with
scale eating fish there are certain fish
depicted here and here that actually
live and survive their ecological niche
is such that they eat scales off of
other larger fish now in the population
of scale eating fish there are some that
have the phenotype called right mouthed
where their mouth is actually more on
the right side of their face and others
that are called left mouthed or their
mouth is more on the left side of their
face and because their mouths are not
perfectly centered but rather to the
right or to the left then they are able
to attach to one of the sides of the
fish whose scales are being eaten to the
right mouthed fish even has its mouth on
the right side and thus attaches to the
left side of the fish the left mounted
fish has its mount on the left side and
thus attaches to the right side of the
fish whose scales it is eating now what
we actually see in practice is that when
there are many many left mouthed
individuals in a population over time
the right mouthed individuals will
increase relative to the left mouth
until they hit approximately a 50/50
percent frequency with the left mouth
scale eating fish if the right mouth
become too common then the left mouth
will become more common in the next
generation and so there's kind of a
balancing act going on where the the
phenotype where one phenotype is going
to be dependent on how much of the other
thena side is present in the population
and this is of course because if you
have a whole bunch of left mouths scale
eating fish and not very many right
mouthed fish well in the next generation
more right mouth fishes are going to
survive simply because there is a niche
for them to fill being on this side of
the fish eating the suspicious scales if
there aren't very many right mouths in
the population then this niche is going
to be open for the next generation to to
come and fill and so that is why over
time we see that the right mouthed fish
and the left mouths fish they are
usually at a 50/50 ratio and when one
starts to become more common then it's
going to be a little bit less common in
the next generation and then more and
less and then they're going to kind of
oscillate back and forth but right
around that 50 percent mark because of
the frequency dependent selection that
is resulting in the maintenance of both
of those forms at relatively stable
frequencies again
around 50% in the population so that is
it for today's video on balancing
selection I hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching biology professor